y en directo américa ahora hablamos de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido iniciamos en rusia donde la
guerra sigue reflejándose en el costo de
los alimentos valentina y la inflación
interanual al 15 de abril se ubicó en 17
62% y es una de las más altas también de
que viven los rusos desde el 2002 según
datos del ministerio de economía y como
consecuencia de la guerra y las
posteriores sanciones los precios de
casi todo desde la apertura la ropa el
azúcar y los teléfonos inteligentes
mostraron alzas agresivas después de que
rusia invadiera a ucrania el 24 de
febrero pasado aunque la inflación
semanal ahí se redujo al 0,20 por ciento
al 15 de abril desde el 066 de la semana
anterior este pequeño alivio permite al
banco central ruso descartar nuevos
aumentos de emergencia a los tipos de
interés y promover una mayor relajación
monetaria pero la inflación también ahí
podría alcanzar entre el 17 y el 20 por
ciento de este año según la cámara de
cuentas rusas
y en canadá también se publicó el dato
de inflación hoy esta es la más alta en
términos anuales al menos en los últimos
31 años la inflación de marzo en canadá
comparada con marzo del año pasado
aumentó 6,7 por ciento muy por encima de
las expectativas de los analistas del 61
por ciento y un punto porcentual más que
en febrero este aumento o esto aumenta
la probabilidad de que el banco de
canadá realice otra subida de tipos de
interés en su próxima reunión de junio
la semana pasada el banco subió los
tipos medio punto porcentual y adelantó
que podrían producirse más subida para
luchar contra la inflación y los precios
de la gasolina subieron en términos
mensuales un 11,8 por ciento y un 39 8%
en los últimos 12 meses esto por
supuesto por la subida internacional de
los precios del petróleo a causa del
conflicto en ucrania es que no se salva
ninguna nación jorge este aumento de los
precios que ya tocó las puertas de
américa latina está provocando medidas
inusuales en américa del sur en uruguay
específicamente dos ciudades comenzaron
a vender alimento porción a 23
peticiones de una gremial de
comerciantes de uruguay las ciudades de
montevideo y canelones habilitaron la
venta de productos fraccionados las
autoridades aprobaron esta medida en la
capital uruguaya durante 180 días y será
vigente para locales comerciales de
hasta 100 metros cuadrados en canelones
que es al sur de uruguay la da a
disposición aplica de comercios de hasta
200 metros cuadrados y la intendencia de
montevideo habilitó a las empresas
productores de elementos a que amplíen
el rango de empaquetado para facilitar
el fraccionamiento a los comerciantes
esta venta de los alimentos de forma
porción nada es habitual en uruguay y en
pequeñas localidades y barrios durante
los periodos de crisis y ahora por la
inflación que azota el monto bueno y
ahora en méxico también busca
contrarrestar la crisis de
semiconductores en la industria el
gigante tecnológico intel y el gobierno
mexicano anunciaron un acuerdo para
fortalecer la cadena de suministros de
semiconductores intel se comprometió en
fortalecer a la competencia
transferir conocimiento y capacitar
talento humano la empresa dijo que
invertiría 8 millones de dólares
tratar a 200 nuevos ingenieros en su
centro de diseño en guadalajara el
anuncio se da cuando la industria
automotriz se enfrenta a la escasez de
estos chips un problema que provocó una
disminución del 2% anual en la
producción de vehículos en méxico en
2021 según datos oficiales este sector
representa el 38 por ciento el producto
interno bruto nacional y el 20.5 por
ciento del pib manufacturero más que
ninguna otra rama comercial jorge
finalizamos esta crónica de economía con
la cifra al día la cifra del día es 54
mil millones eso perdió netflix en la
bolsa tras la caída de los suscriptores
pese al revés en la denominada guerra
del streaming netflix sigue siendo la
frente la líder frente al a disney y
amazon prime vídeo haría usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación y ya nos
conectamos con brasil para nuestro
directo a
[Música]